vers craag bonjour vous suivez pour nous
un ce déplacement c'est une mise en
garde assorti d'un appel tout de même à
vladimir poutine à choisir une voie
pacifique dans ce conflit c'est un peu
toute l'ambiguïté américaine aujourd'hui
agiter le drapeau rouge tout en
poursuivant le dialogue
oui les américains ne veulent pas donner
plus de précisions sur exactement
quelles seraient les conséquences pour
la russie en cas d'action contre
l'ukraine et puis quelle action
entamerait fa déclencherait ses
conséquences il y a eu la semaine
dernière une attaque une cyber attaque
d'envergure sur l'ukraine dont on ne
connaît toujours pas les conséquences le
crâne soupçonne la russie ou peut-être
son allié la biélorussie on n'a pas vu
de conséquence des états unis en
réaction à cela qu est-ce qui qu'est ce
qui déclencherait ses conséquences ça
c'est une question mais clermont le fait
qu anthony blinken entame sa visite en
europe par kiev qu'il rencontre d'abord
le président ukrainien et son homologue
ukrainien avant de rencontrer ses
homologues allemands et russes plus tard
dans la semaine symboliquement c'est in
fine importante pour les ukrainiens qui
se sont aussi aussi je pense réjouit de
ce qu'ils ont vu dans les remarques
quand tony blinken a fait à la presse
américaine juste avant de partir ils
avaient l'air de vraiment vouloir
expliquer aux américains pourquoi
l'ukraine est important pourquoi il
serait inacceptable de laisser la russie
faire ce qu'elle veut et obtenir ce
qu'elle veut on utilisons la menace
militaire de cette façon singulière
comment toutes ces tensions se
sont-elles ressentir aujourd'hui dans la
capitale ukrainienne
alors je te rends compte toujours plus
de personnes qui disent qu'ils n'y
croient pas qu'ils pensent que poutine
bluff que des gens qui ont vraiment peur
mais il est vrai que le pays commence à
mettre en place des choses qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire en cas d' attaque il y
a une carte qui a été dressé par la
mairie de cuivre de kiev des endroits
pouvant servir d'abri par exemple en cas
de bombardement et puis je suis venu ici
devant un bureau de change pour faire ce
direct parce qu'il y a une conséquence
qui se fait sentir depuis quelques jours
pour les ukrainiens c'est l'effet de
toutes ces tensions sur sur le de change
de la monnaie nationale la hryvnia
j'espère que vous voyez derrière moi
elle est à trente deux prévenus a pour
l'euro la semaine dernière il était à 29
elles chutent et les économistes
craignent elles sont unanimes sur le
point que c'est à cause de ces tensions
qui font peur aux investisseurs il ya
d'autres indicateurs aussi qui montre
que les investisseurs hésitent à
investir en ukraine en ce moment c'est
une mauvaise nouvelle pour l'économie
qui montre que rien ton menaçant
vladimir poutine peut faire du mal à
l'ukraine en touchant son économie merci
beaucoup de l'hiver craquant en direct
de kiev où